- I feel like the milk mustaches you see
in the magazines are fake.
- Yeah.
(funky upbeat music)
- I'm a vegetarian, but I love dairy.
- I used to love dairy until dairy
didn't love me anymore,
straight to Lactaid.
(funky upbeat music)
It doesn't give you my classic,
full-fat, white milk look.
- This definitely feels
thicker and creamier.
And yellower?
- It is very...
- Let's give it a taste, shall we?
- Plan.
- This--
- It's like a nutty aftertaste.
- Yeah.
- You know what, this
actually tastes like when
you lick the outside of a peanut.
- When do you lick the
outside of a peanut?
- I could see maybe making
like a milkshake with this,
but I'm not gonna drink this.
(funky upbeat music)
- This is more in line with like
what I think of when I think of milk.
- Smells almondy.
- Oh.
- Is this expired?
- Unsweetened almond milk is
worse than almonds, I think.
- I mean I feel like it's trying
to be skim milk but it's not.
- This is into the milk for me.
- Now this one almost looks translucent.
- Yeah, like if you look--
- This one's like whiter than white.
- If you look at the top,
you could almost like
see through the uppermost layer.
- This is good.
- Oh, it's tasty though.
- This one feels the most,
the closest to normal.
- It tastes very strongly
of rice.
- Almost, I love this.
- There you go!
(funky upbeat music)
- You know what this looks like?
It looks like glue.
- Oh, oh that is strong.
- This is like the lightest flavor for me,
the most passable, the most like milk.
To me.
- Yeah, I agree.
- It definitely has a little
less sweet and enticing
like bold flavor.
- Yeah.
It's got that fattiness,
I like the fattiness.
- I am undecided.
- It tastes like--
- Undecided, sorry, that's not
how much I didn't like the milk.
It's not going anywhere,
it's just Elmer's.
- Elmer's Coconut Milk,
it will stick with you.
- This one has a real big--
- Warmer.
- So I like the beginning,
but I don't love the end.
- It was very thick.
- I feel like all of the moisture
in my mouth has just been sucked out.
- This is what we've been waiting for.
- Already, this is is gray.
- It's gray and it tastes like gray.
- Ugh, I'm not a fan of this though.
This is like the loser of milks.
- Cashews are honestly
like the upper-class nut
and then the milk--
- Oh, well now you're saying
that it's separate, it makes me
feel better that I don't mind it.
I like my milk fancy.
- Rice stole the show today,
it was all about rice.
Rice was the Beyonce.
- Yeah.
And everybody else was in the show,
I gotta say.
- Wait a minute here.
- I couldn't just drink it,
drink any of these straight.
I think I could maybe
try incorporating them
with other things?
- Yeah.
- I don't know if I'd like
jump to these as an alternative
or if I'd use any of them.
- Yeah.
I'm gonna hold out for as long
as I can deal with lactose.
(cow mooing)
(funky upbeat music)